these people are just absolute maniacs
but what happens when you're a
progressive maniac you get on all of the
tv shows and you get to be uh
basically massaged by uh stephen colbert
who's one of the least funny people in
the history of the world for three
segments she did three segments last
night not just like a two minute thing
she did three full segments oh full
chock full of comedy here's just a tiny
bit
uh you know there's some speculation as
to whether president biden is going to
run in 2024 there's some there's some
reports he's a little frustrated that
people keep asking because he keeps on
saying yes and people go are you sure
are you sure
um you know uh i know somebody who's
gonna turn 35
uh about a month before the election in
2024
and uh they represent new york's 14th uh
is is that job appealing to you at all
um i think that theoretically uh listen
i think that we need to focus on keeping
a democracy
for anybody to be president
in the next couple of years and that's
my central focus is helping the people
of this country so it's possible so it's
possible
[Applause]
first off putting aside her fake
laughter and just the way the whole
machine massages her and you can see
they're pushing biting out joe you fool
and i get your muddled and confused and
you didn't know what you were getting
into in the first place and there's a
special place in hell for dr jill biden
because of what she's done to you but
they're pushing you out old man and you
can see how the machine's doing it
colbert i mean when they do these things
this is all planned he works for cbs
it's a giant corporation that basically
is telling him what to say through a
series of writers and executive
producers and all of those things and
we're lee okay let's start talking to
aoc remember just remember a month ago
nobody was talking about if there's
anything wrong with biden if he's too
mentally compromised or whatever else it
might be now everyone's kind of talking
about it and guess what that's going to
keep going as his approval ratings keep
going down so the machine is pushing you
out the old bastard and it's going to
now prop up this crazed communist
oh i i wanted to do it
i was going to do c word i was going to
do c word i didn't do it i didn't do it
my better angels were thank you thank
you for that here she is screaming about
what she's going to do
related to abortions
i'll start with the babies of the
babiest of the baby steps open abortion
clinics on federal lands
[Applause]
do you realize how twisted it is however
she repeatedly said the baby of the baby
of the baby steps while she's talking
about abortion like these people are
genuinely evil i just don't know how to
say it in any other way uh what she's
calling for there is abortion clinics on
federal land now the supreme court just
has decided through the reversal of roe
that the federal government has nothing
to do with abortion so i'm fairly
certain the federal government funding
abortion meaning using federal funds for
something that the supreme court has
just decided has nothing to do with the
federal government would be illegal i
know they don't care about the
constitution they don't care about the
supreme court unless it does what they
want and all of that